[musique]
Et c'est parti. Laurent Alexandre,
bonjour. Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle
Serview. Nous voulons avoir vos
lumières, votre raisonnement sur
l'intelligence artificielle quand vous
aurez lâché votre portable d'homme
d'affaires.
On est en direct. Comment allez-vous ?
Très bien,
ça va. Merci d'être venu jusqu'ici
depuis Bruxelles jusqu'à Saint-Denis.
Euh je tenais tout d'abord pour
commencer cette interview à rectifier
quelque chose. Vous n'êtes pas un
connard, un but de votre personne qui
prend 5000 € par conférence. On a testé
Laurent Alexandre pendant un mois au
téléphone, même le weekend et vous êtes
très accessible, cool, relaxe et vous
venez jusque à à Saint-Enit à 10h30 du
matin pour discuter avec des hackurs
bénévoles. Bonjour. Qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'intelligence artificielle ?
[soupir]
Que ça va nous occuper quelques
milliards d'années,
qu'on est
en pleine incertitude,
que ça va être un bordel
inommable, qu'on projette sur
l'intelligence artificielle tous nos
fantasmes entre ceux qui imaginent un
futur extraordinaire où l'homme va
devenir un homme dieu grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle. et puis
ceux qui cauchemardent et qui imaginent
que l'intelligence artificielle va nous
igouiller dès les années 2030 2040 comme
Elon Mosque les mauvais jours. On va
avoir tous les ventails. Donc on va être
dans un bordel économique, social,
politique, intellectuel.
On va avoir beaucoup de mal à savoir où
on va. On est dans un grand brouillard.
Plein de gens auront des certitudes qui
se révéleront toutes fausses. Ça va être
difficile de trouver un chemin
notamment pour des raisons éducatives et
c'est ma grande angoisse, c'est que je
je crains que Harari dans Homodéus
raison. C'est-à-dire qu'on aille vers
des dieux et des inutiles, c'est-à-dire
une aristocratie de l'intelligence et
puis de l'autre côté des gens pour
lequels le monde va devenir trop
compliqué.
Euh
c'est pour moi une grande crainte
politique.
Politique dans quel sens ? Le pouvoir
politique va pas pouvoir gérer la
transition, n'est pas câblé pour, n'est
pas équipé pour ou simplement défendre
? Non, je pense que le pouvoir politique
se fout
du fait qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
laisser pour compte.
On voit bien que il n'y a aucune volonté
à
à l'échelle internationale de rénover
l'éducation, de réfléchir à des méthodes
éducatives pour réduire les inégalités
intellectuelles. En réalité, les élites
politiques de droite et de gauche ont
déjà intégré le paradigme de Harari,
c'est-à-dire, on va avoir une un petit
groupe de 10 à 15 % de la population
tout mouillée qui va gérer le monde de
demain et qui va organiser
l'intelligence artificielle. Puis on va
avoir une masse très importante de gens
qui [grognement] n'auront pas une
formation adéquate et puis qu'on va
mettre à la fin au revenu universel. Et
le revenu universel, c'est une idée
extrêmement conservatrice. C'est pas une
idée bienveillante. Le revenu universel,
ça veut dire nous n'allons pas
moderniser l'école parce que c'est trop
compliqué de moderniser l'école. On va
vous [__] dans un coin. On va vous
donner de quoi vous payez
la téléréalité et du pain et on va
surtout pas essayer de vous rendre
compétitif de l'intelligence
artificielle. Le revenu universel est
l'idée la plus conservatrice que j'ai vu
de toute ma vie. Et ça passe pour une
idée de gauche alors que c'est une idée
d'un mépris absolu et total pour les
classes populaires qu'on considère comme
perdu face à l'intelligence artificielle
et dont on considère qu'il est
impossible de les rendre compétitives
par l'éducation, la formation.
Le revenu universel est une idée qui me
révulse et de la et de voir qu'elle est
conçue comme une idée de gauche alors
que c'est une idée d'extrême droite me
choque profondément.
Pour vous, c'est un déni, une forfaiture
ou c'est simplement est-ce que le
pouvoir politique mise plutôt sur de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
encadrer, surveiller et peut-être lisser
les comportements pour pouvoir que le
moule s'emboî correctement.
C'est pas comme ça.
Il y a pas de complot de la part des
élites politiques. Simplement faire
évoluer l'éducation est trop lourd, trop
compliqué. Donc on considère qu'on n'y
arrivera pas. Et les politiques sont pas
complètement cons. Il voit très bien que
l'intelligence artificielle va
radicalement changer le marché du
travail. Donc il raisonne très
simplement. On peut pas moderniser
l'école en profondeur.
Et d'un autre côté, l'intelligence
artificielle va déqualifier beaucoup de
gens.
qu'on ne va pas pouvoir former. Donc, on
trouve une solution d'assistance,
d'assistanaat profondément paternaliste
euh au lieu de de se poser les vraies
questions sur comment on réorganise
l'économie et comment on réorganise
l'école. Et ce sont des questions qui ne
sont pas simples.
Vous avez trouvé des pistes ?
Et ben des pistes aujourd'hui, on en a
pas. On en a pas. On peut améliorer
l'école, on peut personnaliser l'école
bien sûr et l'intelligence artificielle
peut d'ailleurs aider à personnaliser
la façon dont on est formé en fonction
de nos caractéristiques intellectuelles
personnelles parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle la personnalisation de de
l'enseignement ou l'adaptative learning.
Le problème c'est que ça va pas suffire.
Le et c'est sans doute le grand tabou de
l'éducation. L'éducation, la formation
sont des technologies merveilleuses et
on doit tous énormément à à l'éducation.
Qu'elle soit publique et ou privée, ça
ne change pas grand-chose. L'éducation
est une technologie merveilleuse. Elle a
juste un immense problème. L'éducation
marche très très bien sur les caution
intellectuels élevés. Elle marche
moyennement bien sur les caution
intellectuels moyens. Et l'éducation ne
marche quasiment pas sur les cautions
intellectuels faibles, sur les caution
intellectuelles médiocres. Autrement
dit, investir sur l'école, former les
gens, ça profite d'abord aux gens les
plus intelligents. Toutes les études
montrent que les gens qui ont des
capacités intellectuelles moyennes hélas
ne bénéficient pas beaucoup du système
éducatif. On le voit tous les jours,
d'expliquer un truc compliqué à un
polytechnicien, c'est plus facile et ça
va plus vite que de l'expliquer à un
cantonnier.
C'est vrai, c'est pas politiquement
correct, mais c'est la réalité.
L'horrible réalité, c'est que le
quotient intellectuel mesure notre
capacité à apprendre
et que les gens les moins doués qui vont
être le plus bousculés par
l'intelligence artificielle sont aussi
les gens qui ont le plus de mal à
apprendre des choses nouvelles. On s'est
beaucoup moqué de de Macron quand il
avait parlé de la reconversion des
ouvrières de Gade. Mais c'est vrai,
former les ouvrières de Gade à un
nouveau métier, c'est compliqué.
Ce sont des femmes tout à fait
valeureuses qui ont une dignité
tout à fait équivalente à tous les
autres hommes, mais elles ont des
capacités cognitives qui ne sont pas
extraordinaires
et effectivement elles ont du mal à
apprendre des nouvelles choses. Elles ne
savent pas elles ne savent pas
apprendre. Et aujourd'hui, si on voulait
être révolutionnaire,
il faudrait investir
d'un point de vue universitaire en
recherche pour trouver des formes de
pédagogie, des formes d'éducation qui
marchent bien chez les gens qui ont des
cuits médiocres
parce que cela permettrait de réduire
les inégalités intellectuelles et donc
les inégalités tout courts. Parce que
dans le monde où nous rentrons qui est
une économie de la connaissance, le
pouvoir, les revenus vont être
directement corrélés à nos capacités
intellectuel. Si nous n'avons pas les
moyens de réduire les inégalités
intellectuelles,
nous allons avoir d'énormes inégalités
sociales, professionnelles et
économique.
C'est déjà le cas, non ?
Ça va être bien pire. Il y a dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui de la place pour des
gens qui n'ont pas une forte
intelligence conceptuelle. Quand
l'intelligence artificielle va être
ubiquitaire, va être présente partout,
il n'y aura plus de place économique
pour des gens qui n'ont pas une forte
intelligence conceptuelle.
C'est horrible à dire, mais
progressivement dans les décennies qui
viennent, la place des gens qui n'ont
pas une intelligence conceptuelle forte
va être difficile à trouver. Et donc en
maintenant des inégalités
intellectuelles fortes entre les gens,
on va créer en réalité des inégalités
sociales explosives.
Car pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité,
on n' pas besoin dans le système
économique de gens qui n'ont pas une
forte intelligence conceptuelle. Ce
constat, il est horrible, il est très
triste, mais il faut bien le faire,
notamment si nous voulons investir dans
la recherche pédagogique pour trouver
des méthodes pédagogiques comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui permettent
d'aider à mieux apprendre aux gens qui
ne savent pas apprendre.
À partir de combien de points de cuivrez
un intellect moyen ?
L'intellectuel moyen, une intelligence
moyenne est autour de 100.
Classiquement, les surdoués sont
au-dessus de 130 et en dessous de 70, on
considère que les gens ont des grandes
difficultés intellectuelles, voire des
des des handicaps mentaux.
Vous avez combien de cuits ?
Ça n'a aucun intérêt.
C'est une question qui a été posée sur
internet.
Ça n'a aucun intérêt. Euh
le problème politique, c'est qu'on est
rentré dans une économie de la
connaissance sans en tirer toutes les
conclusions. Dans une économie de la
connaissance, dans une économie de la
data, dans une économie de
l'intelligence artificielle, il y a par
définition une énorme prime à ceux qui
ont une forte intelligence conceptuelle,
à ceux qui sont innovants, à ceux qui
savent manuer manier la data
ou les plus prédateurs, les plus cupides
ou ceux qui ont été sélectionnés par
l'école pour avoir des comportements de
plus en plus agressifs envers leur leur
leurs collègues.
Si vous pensez que le pouvoir est détenu
par des gens qui sont malhonnêtes, vous
vous trompez. Le pouvoir est toujours
tenu par les gens les plus intelligents.
C'est vrai en politique aussi. Si
Mélenchon
est le chef des insoumis, c'est pas
parce qu'il colle les affiches mieux que
les autres, c'est parce qu'il est le
plus intelligent chez les insoumis.
Mélanchon a le pouvoir chez les insoumis
parce qu'il est extrêmement intelligent.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le rencontrer. Il
a un caution intellectuel extrêmement
élevé, presque aussi élevé que celui
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Macron a combien ?
Macron a sans doute 160 170 de caution
intellectuelle. Macron est un grand
surdoué. On aime ou on aime pas Macron
mais il a une intelligence
exceptionnelle.
On parle beaucoup d'intelligence de
coent intellectuel. Ici vous êtes dans
un territoire où on est relativement
bien fourni.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du quotient
émotionnel des valeurs qu'on pourrait
inculquer l'intelligence artificielle ?
Alors, le qucient émotionnel est est un
truc rigolo, c'est-à-dire on fait comme
si le caution émotionnel et le caution
intellectuel n'était pas lié. Autrement
dit, les gens à haut caution
intellectuel seraient des salots ne
comprenant pas les autres sans émotion
et puis les gens bêtes, ils auraient
beaucoup plus d'empathie, beaucoup plus
d'émotions que les autres. Non, c'est
une vision sympathique, romantique mais
fausse. Le quotient émotionnel, il est
assez bien corrélé au quent
intellectuel. Hélas, les différentes
formes d'intelligence sont toutes
corrélées entre elles. Elles sont toutes
corrélées à ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence générale. Et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des inégalités. Si nous
avions tous les tous les mêmes capacités
intellectuelles, il n'y aurait pas
d'inégalité dans la société. Nous
aurions une société égalitaire. Les
différences dans la société sont des
différences de capacité intellectuelle.
L'intelligence est hélas.
la source, la clé de tous les pouvoirs,
le pouvoir technologique, le pouvoir
scientifique, le pouvoir universitaire,
le pouvoir politique, le pouvoir
financier, le pouvoir entrepreneurial.
On peut refuser de voir cette réalité.
Ce sont les gens les plus malins et les
plus innovants qui tiennent la queue du
Mickey et qui ont toutes les clés du
pouvoir. Cela toujours été comme ça,
mais demain dans la société de
l'intelligence artificielle, ça va être
pire. Quand on va se retrouver avec une
intelligence artificielle avec un Q à
10000 points,
est-ce qu'elle prendra le pouvoir ?
Qu'est-ce que vous considérez comme le
pouvoir ?
Alors,
l'intelligence artificielle va-t-elle
nous dépasser ou pas ? est un débat que
personne ne peut trancher aujourd'hui.
Ce qu'on a aujourd'hui, ce sont des
intelligences artificielles faibles,
c'estàdire qu'ils n'ont pas conscience
d'elles-même et qui sont pas du tout
capable de dépasser un humain parce
qu'elles ne sont pas
multidisciplinaires.
Comme je le dis souvent, les
intelligences artificielles actuelles
sont cons comme des [__] et elles vont
le rester. C'est-à-dire elles ne sont
pas capables d'associer des savoirs de
plusieurs domaines et ça va rester vrai
pendant encore plusieurs décennies.
Elle ressemble beaucoup à des autistes
de type Asperger, c'est-à-dire capable
d'apprendre par cœur le bottin, capable
de jouer aux échecs merveilleusement,
capable de faire des calculs de tête et
de retrouver les 10000 premières
décimales de PI en quelques secondes,
mais incapable de faire un café.
Euh ell ce sont ce sont donc des formes
d'intelligence particulières qui ne sont
pas des intelligences humaines. Et
la supériorité de l'intelligence humaine
par rapport à l'intelligence
artificielle, c'est que nous on est
transversal, on est multidisciplinaire,
on a du bon sens que l'intelligence
artificielle n'a pas. Est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle peut
l'acquérir ? Il y a des gens qui le
craignent comme Bill Gates, comme
Hawkins, comme Elon Mosk. Il y a des
gens comme Marc Zuckerberg qui pensent
que ça n'est pas réaliste dans les euh
30 prochaines années,
50 prochaines années.
Il est aujourd'hui impossible de
trancher cette question. C'est une
question intéressante d'un point de vue
universitaire et politique parce que
s'il y avait des intelligences
artificielles fortes, elle risquerait de
devenir hostile. Mais c'est pas la
question du moment. La question du
moment, c'est comment on fait pour les
gens pas très doués pour arriver à
rester compétitif dans un monde où
l'intelligence artificielle faible, sans
conscience d'elle-même, va être quasi
gratuite et va faire les choses beaucoup
plus vite que nous. Que fait-on d'un
comptable quand l'intelligence
artificielle, même si elle ne sait pas
qu'elle existe, va faire les comptes un
milliard de fois plus vite que le
comptable et pour trois cacahuètes ?
C'est cette question là qui se pose.
C'est une question politique, c'est une
question éducative, c'est une question
philosophique. On n pas commencé à y
réfléchir. Il est urgent d'y réfléchir
sinon nous allons avoir une crise
sociale. Et comme je disais tout à
l'heure, Arari dans Homodéus aura
raison. Nous aurons une aristocratie de
l'intelligence d'un côté avec une masse
de gens abandonnés. Et cette vision
d'horreur, cette vision politique
d'horreur, ce cauchemar politique est en
fait ce qu'on est en train de
construire. en ne réformant pas
l'éducation et la formation suffisamment
vite, même si des efforts méritoires
sont faits en ce moment en France.
Récemment, on a reçu Mounir Majoui,
ministre du numérique, secrétaire d'État
attaché au numérique. Il nous a parlé de
l'intelligence artificielle et de ces
nouveaux emplois qui allaient être
créés. Est-ce que vous avez une opinion
là-dessus ? Vous avez anticipé les
choses ?
Il va y avoir
des millions de nouveaux emplois.
Il y a des millions de choses nouvelles
que va faire l'humanité dans les
prochains millions d'années
et dans les prochaines décennies si on
veut raisonner à plus court terme. La
colonisation du cosmos, comprendre notre
cerveau, guérir toutes les maladies
affreuses qu'on ne sait toujours pas
guérir. L'amopathie tue encore dans les
formes graves 100 % des gamins touchés.
Le cancer tue encore 50 % des Français
touchés aujourd'hui. L'aventure humaine
n'est qu'à son début. L'aventure humaine
est-il limité ? Il y a plein de choses à
faire. Il y a plein de domaines où nous
allons faire des choses extraordinaires
avec l'intelligence artificielle. Il y a
juste un problème dans cette économie.
Nous n'avons pas bien réfléchi à ce que
nous allons faire des gens pas très
doués, pas très innovants, ne sachant
pas très bien manipuler les données,
l'intelligence artificielle.
Bref, une fois de plus, nous sommes face
à un problème politique angoissant. Nous
allons vers un monde extraordinaire
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle,
mais qui risque d'être un monde
fantastique,
principalement pour les gens les plus
doués et dotés d'une forte intelligence
conceptuelle.
C'est une forme de génisme du 21e
siècle.
Non, c'est une forme d'appartide. En
réalité, les politiques ont intériorisé
l'idée qu'on allait créer une société à
de vitesse. S'il n'avait pas intériorisé
cette idée-là, on moderniserait l'école
et la formation professionnelle 10 fois
plus vite qu'on le fait dans les pays
européens. Non, il n'est jamais trop
tard.
On a peut-être plus de sous.
Il n'est jamais trop tard. Vu le nombre
de rond-points inutiles qu'on fait à la
sortie des villages, vu la façon dont on
gaspie de l'argent public dans les
régions et au niveau national
aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas dire qu'on
manque d'argent. L'argent est mal
utilisé. Il ne va pas vers les deux
seules priorités
du 21e siècle, la recherche et
l'éducation. On met l'argent partout, on
soupoude les tasprovidence partout. Les
gamins de bourgeois ont des bourses
inutiles, ont des allocations inutiles.
L'État providence gaspille du pognon
partout, on rembourse plein de
médicaments inutiles. Non, il y a plein
d'argent, sauf que l'argent est
distribué en fonction des désirs des
lobby au lieu d'aller vers les deux
seules priorités de la France au 21e
siècle pour éviter cet apparta
d'intellectuel que sont la recherche et
l'éducation. Est-ce que Est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle pour les
politiques ce n'est pas leur prochain
cliqué maltusien ? Est-ce que vous
connaissez la notion de cliquer
maltusien ?
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez par cliquer
En gros, quand [raclement de gorge] on a
découvert l'agriculture, ça nous a
permis de grossir notre population,
d'évoluer au niveau de notre
démographie. Quand on a découvert le
gaz, l'électricité, le pétrole, le
charbon, ça nous a fait faire un bon. ce
qui nous a permis d'encore grossir notre
population. Est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle va permettre de maintenir
cette fonction exponentielle sur notre
démographie ? Est-ce que ma question est
suffisamment claire ?
Ah, dans ce sens-là, d'accord.
La population dans les pays occidentaux
ne va pas monter. Donc on sait bien
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une seule zone sur
terre où la population va encore
beaucoup monter, c'est l'Afrique. Sur
l'Asie, c'est en train de se tasser et
progressivement la population asiatique
va se stabiliser mais l'Afrique va
monter à 4 milliards et demi d'années.
Donc 4 milliards et demi de d'habitants.
Donc globalement hors Afrique la
situation démographique elle est elle
est stabilisée. Il est pas question
d'avoir plus de monde. Alors il y a des
gens qui souhaitent qu'il y ait plus de
monde parce qu'ils veulent pouvoir
coloniser le cosmos. hein. Récemment,
Jeff Bezos, le patron d'Amazon,
expliquait qu'il faudrait 1000 milliards
de terriens pour coloniser notre voie
notre Voie lactée. Mais la question
démographique, elle va se régler
progressivement. Il va y avoir une grave
crise en Afrique, mais en dehors de
l'Afrique, on va stabiliser la situation
entre 2050 et 2080. On va sortir de la
crise démographique après un dernier
sous-bressau qui est l'Afrique.
Je suis pas très inquiet sur le plan
démographique.
Pourquoi vous êtes intéressé à ce
sujet-là en particulier ? Vous avez une
formation, vous avez appris à coder,
vous avez des petites notions sur les
réseaux neuronaux, vous avez mis les
mains un peu sous le capot ou pas du
tout ?
Moi, je suis pas un technicien de
l'intelligence artificielle. Je
m'intéresse aux conséquences politiques.
Quand je suis rentré dans ce domaine-là,
j'ai vu plein de gens très compétents,
plein d'informaticiens
euh très fort, j'ai vu plein de
mathématiciens géniaux. J'ai vu
personnes qui réfléchissaient aux
conséquences politiques, sociales,
éducatives de l'intelligence
artificielle. J'ai vu des gens le nez
sur le guidon qui réfléchissaient à
l'algorithme incapable de voir ce que le
tsunami de l'intelligence artificielle
allait faire à 1 an, 5 ans, 10 ans, 50
ans, 1000 ans, un million d'années.
Aucune réflexion
parce que les gens de l'intelligence
artificielle n'ont pas de pensée
politique, ils n'ont pas de pensée
sociale, ils n'ont pas de pensée
économique. Et donc ça m'a donné envie
de réfléchir aux conséquences politiques
de ces sujets-là sur lesquels nous
étions en plein désert. C'est pas
spécifique à la France. La silicone
vallée ne réfléchit que très très peu
aux conséquences politiques de
l'intelligence artificielle. Vous avez
des contacts un peu avec les milieux
militaires, l'armée, est-ce qu'il
s'intéresse à ce type de
les militaires, les militaires ont
longtemps ignorer l'intelligence
artificielle et puis aujourd'hui avec
les cyberattaques, il commence à à
réfléchir. Il y a des gens qui sont qui
qui
en France qui sont pas mauvais
là-dessus, même s'ils n'aiment pas qu'on
qu'on les cite parce que l'armée, la
grande metette est toujours est toujours
très discrète. Il est clair que la
guerre au 21e siècle sera une guerre
entre intelligence artificielle et que
si la puissance adverse a une
intelligence artificielle supérieure à
la vôtre, vos missiles ne décolleront
pas, vos avions ne décolleront pas et
vos bombes n'exploseront pas. Donc nous
rentrons dans une guerre qui va être une
guerre totalement nouvelle, qui va être
une guerre numérique, une guerre
informationnelle.
Les militaires commencent à le
comprendre, la France commence à
investir sur ces sujets-là.
face à la Chine et les États aux
États-Unis, elle ne compte pas. La seule
unité pertinente, si on voulait demain
être compétitif sur le plan militaire,
c'est l'Europe. Or, avec le Brexit, la
seule autre puissance nucléaire que la
France en Europe est en train de
s'éloigner de l'Europe, le Brexit est un
drame pour l'unité militaire de la
France de de l'Europe. Ça laisse
l'Europe avec une seule puissance
nucléaire qui n'a plus beaucoup
d'argent. la France, on risque d'être
sous critique et
j'ai peur qu'il n'y ait demain que deux
puissances militaires, la Chine et les
États-Unis.
Oui, les Russes, ils vont être balayés.
Euh les Russes ont quelques experts en
intelligence artificielle mais ils sont
pas capables de se battre. Il faut pas
oublier que la Russie est aujourd'hui
une puissance technologique mineure
hein. La production totale de la Russie
est très inférieure à la production
française alors même que la Russie a 140
millions d'habitants.
L'intelligence artificielle sur les
marchés financiers, l'hyperfancy
[raclement de gorge]
trading, toutes ces joyeusés. Est-ce que
vous pensez pas que une intelligence
artificielle qui a appris à réagir dans
un certain contexte ou qui a appris à
réagir avec des certaines personnes qui
l'ont qui l'ont un petit peu entraîné ne
va pas pouvoir réagir correctement face
à des
signes noirs sur les marchés ?
L'intelligence artificielle ne va pas
voir les signes noirs, je ne le pense
pas
et elle va pas créer plus de crises
qu'il y en a eu avant. le Grand Crage de
1987, hein, il est lié à des raisons euh
euh techniques, il a été amplifié par
des raisons techniques, il y avait pas
d'intelligence artificielle. 1929, il y
avait pas d'intelligence artificielle.
Je ne crois pas que les crises vont être
augmentées par l'intelligence
artificielle.
2007-211, les flashes craquent. Non,
il y a déjà eu des crashes pour des
raisons techniques, par des par des
manipulations, même quand on était
encore à la plume d'oig et au papier au
19e siècle. Je ne crois pas que
l'intelligence artificielle va augmenter
la fréquence des crises parce qu'on va
aussi servir de l'intelligence
artificielle pour réduire les crises.
Donc il va y avoir un équilibre comme
d'habitude qui va s'établir.
Le fameux équilibre. Euh vous avez
entendu parler de l'intelligence
artificielle de Microsoft qui a été
lâché sur internet sur Twitter et qui a
été un petit peu entraîné par
Ouais, j'en ai fait j'en ai fait un
papier dans l'Express. Ouais. Qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez quand elle s'est mise
que l'intelligence artificielle dont on
parle qui est une intelligence
artificielle extrêmement faible qui est
un chatbot c'est-à-dire les chatbotes
sont davantage des escroqueries que des
réalités en matière d'intelligence
artificielle en 2017 he je parle pas du
futur
générer du trafic sur les sites
donc chat un chatbot par définition
séduque à partir des conversations qu'il
écoutent et quand il n'y a que des
néonazies des antiféministes des ultra
réactionnaires et des homophobes sur un
forum
Par définition, le chatbot va devenir
anti-homosexuel,
anti-femme, anti-juif, antiblac,
profondément raciste. C'est logique,
c'est normal. Il ne peut pas en être
autrement avec cette technologie là.
Donc effectivement, les chatbotes ne
sont pas une bonne technologie si on
veut que le web soit un web de tolérance
et pas un web raciste et homophobe.
On va on va reparler de qui entraînent
les intelligences artificielles.
Certains avaient émis l'hypothèse de la
faire entraîner par des moines
bouddhistes. Qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ?
La question de la morale et de
l'intelligence artificielle, elle est
vachement compliquée.
On est persuadé d'être très moral. On
est persuadé d'avoir une morale
parfaite. On est persuadé d'avoir une
morale universelle. Quand [grognement]
on prend un tout petit peu de recul, on
se rend compte que notre morale, elle
est contingente. Elle varie dans le
temps, elle varie dans l'espace. Il y a
pas de morale universelle. Il faut
l'éduquer comment ? L'intelligence
artificielle ? Avec la morale du Coran,
avec la morale de la Torah, avec la
morale du de l'Ancien Testament. du
Nouveau Testament avec la morale
bouddhiste, avec une morale athée. Il
faut lui apprendre quoi ? Il faut lui
apprendre la morale des années 50 60
quand on faisait des lobotomies
au Canada pour des garçons qui se
masturbaient trop, ce qui était
considéré comme très moral à l'époque et
ça parce que la masturbation était
encore vue comme un péché.
C'est ça qu'il faut donner comme moral à
la à l'intelligence artificielle. Est-ce
qu'il faut lui donner la morale de 1880
? Est-ce qu'il faut lui donner la morale
de la manif pour tous ou la morale de
ceux qui sont favorables au mariagiers ?
Quelle est la morale qui s'impose à
l'intelligence artificielle ? Bah la
réponse qu'on va pas trouver de moral
universel parce qu'il y a pas de moral
universel et qu'on va avoir des conflits
éthiques terribles,
des conflits moraux terrible et qu'il va
bien falloir qu'on explicite notre
morale. Dans le cas de la selve Draving
Car, il va falloir qu'on explicite si on
pense la voiture autonome, si on pense
qu'il vaut mieux écraser trois
vieillards ou deux enfants de 10 ans si
les freins lâchent, et ben il va falloir
qu'on se mouille et qu'on le dise. Pour
vous, on écrase plutôt les vieux ou les
jeunes ? Pour moi, il vaut mieux écraser
trois mecs de mon âge que d'écraser deux
enfants de 10 ans. C'est mon point de
vue parce que je considère que quelqu'un
de mon âge vaut moins qu'un enfant de 10
ans. J'ai déjà vécu, j'ai déjà fait
plein de choses. Un enfant de 10 ans n'a
pas encore fait grand-chose. Je
considère qu'il n'est pas euh
Et votre capacité à transmettre va être
perdue. C'est un peu comme un pilote de
chasse. Un pilote de chasse.
Oui. Et je considère que ma dignité
personnelle et mon utilité
est moins importante que celle d'un
enfant de 10 ans. Et puis j'ai déjà vécu
57 ans. Un enfant n'a vécu que 10 ans.
Je pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'elle écrase
moi plutôt qu'un gamin de 10 ans. Mais
c'est un point de vue totalement
personnel et je comprends tout à fait
quelqu'un qui pense que qui penserait le
contraire. Mais c'est ma vision. Et mais
là encore, on voit qu'il va être
difficile de trancher et d'expliquer à
l'intelligence artificielle des voitures
autonomes ce qui est mieux. Un vieux con
déjà âgé qui a déjà vécu ou des jeunes
enfants qui ont encore tout à créer.
Sole, vous avez vu Soleil Vert ?
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Que c'est une dystopie écologiste comme
on en connaît depuis Maltus. On va tous
mourir, il y aura plus à manger. On va
on va tous être malheureux. Je vous
rappelle que Maltus il y a 250 ans était
persuadé que ben enfin il y a oui 200
ans était persuadé que
euh l'Angleterre allait crever de faim
dès lors qu'on allait dépasser 5
millions d'habitants. Comme vous savez,
ils sont 65 millions d'habitants dont 40
% d'obèse. Donc la vision de Maltus
s'est révélée fausse. Toutes les visions
maltusiennes se sont toujours révélées
fausses. On va pas mourir de faim. Il y
a de quoi mourir 20 ou 30 milliards de
personnes sur terre, même si certains
écologistes
extrémistes, certains ayat vert veulent
croire que nous allons vers des
pénuries. Mais cette vision cette vision
d'un monde de pénurie a toujours été une
vision fausse et elle a toujours été
colleportée par des gens pessimistes que
je soupçonne d'être déprimé.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
collapsologie ?
C'est une question duun nette que je
résume.
Collapsologie,
c'est cette vision
des petits vieux et des petits vieilles
et et de certains écolos profondément
pessimistes. Tout va aller mal mais il y
a des gens déprimés et parmi les gens
déprimés, il y en a beaucoup qui sont
pas traités.
La différence entre déprimé et réaliste
pour vous.
La différence entre déprimé et réaliste,
c'est qu'il faut soigner les déprimés.
et que beaucoup de déprimés ne sont pas
pris en charge, sont malheureux.
D'ailleurs,
certains suicident tellement ils pensent
que l'avenir noir
va être horrible noir. Il préfèrent
mourir que de d'affronter que
d'affronter un avenir qu'il perçoivent
de façon
faire des enfants. Non ou pas faire
d'enfants.
Je connais des écologistes parmi mes
amis qui ne font pas d'enfants parce
qu'ils imaginent que le monde de demain
va être tellement horrible, va tellement
ressembler à Soleil Vert qu'il préfèrent
rester euh égoïste tout seul avec leur
chat plutôt que de fonder une famille
chat tout le temps. Bon, revenons un peu
à notre intelligence artificielle.
Euh
oui, parce que le chat vivant moins
longtemps qu'un enfant, il considère que
le chat ne sera pas confronté au monde
horrible qui se profile. [soupir][rires]
OK.
À l'heure actuelle, vous êtes juste
légèrement augmenté. Vous avez un
téléphone portable, une monde connectée,
un thermostat connecté chez vous. Est-ce
que vous voyez dans un proche à venir
vous faire un peu augmenter pour être à
notre à notre niveau ?
Alors, d'abord, les technologies
d'augmentation cérébrale, elles vont pas
être là demain matin, elles seront pas
là avant 2035 2040, hein. Neuralink, la
nouvelle société d'Elon Mosque destinée
à à nous augmenter va pas être
opérationnel. rapidement. Donc on a le
temps.
Donc je ne serai pas concerné. Je serai
en Alzheimer avant que les technologies
d'augmentation cérébrale ne soient au
point. Donc je ne suis pas concerné. Ça
va concerner en revanche les futures
générations.
Il va falloir y réfléchir. Alors on a le
temps parce que c'est pas des
technologies qui sont là demain matin
mais il va quand même falloir réfléchir
à ce que la société fait de ces
technologies là. Le jour où les implants
intracébron de Noralink sont au point,
on va avoir plein de problèmes moraux et
éthiques. Certains parents vont
accepter.
Que feront les enfants qui n'auront pas
été augmentés ? Peut-on interdire à
certains parents de mettre des
microprocesseurs Neuralink d'Elon Mosque
dans le cerveau de leurs enfants le jour
où ça fonctionne, le jour où ça existe ?
des questions compliquées, hein. Est-ce
qu'on aura le droit d'interdire à un
paysan tanzanien pauvre de mettre des
implants cérébraux dans le cerveau de
ses enfants pour qu'il puisse faire
Harvard ?
Pourra-t-il payer au nom de quel moral
on va aller lui dire non, tes enfants
doivent rester pauvres
et stupides
et avec un cuit normal et on t'interdit
d'augmenter le cuit de tes enfants pour
qu'ils puissent faire Harvard. Au nom de
quel moral on va aller dire ça ? Un
paysan tantien pauvre en 2050 ? Je sais
pas très bien, mais une fois qu'on
accepte que le paysan tanzanien le
fasse,
c'est un peu compliqué quand on a un
gamin
qui a fait des toutes petites études, il
va être un petit peu défavorisé par
rapport au gamin du paysan tanzanien et
donc j'ai peur qu'on rentre dans un
toboggan difficile à arrêter, dans une
surenchère intellectuelle où tout le
monde va chercher à augmenter sans fin
le caution intellectuel de sa
progéniture. ce qu'il a pour le pour de
bon créerait une multitude de
sous-groupes pouvant éventuellement
avoir du mal à communiquer.
Vous vous parlez dans votre bouquin vers
la fin d'une rencontre du troisème type.
Est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu
délayer ce passage là ?
Si demain on a une intelligence
artificielle forte, c'est ce que
j'explique dans dans mon bouquin, la
guerre des intelligences. Si on a demain
une intelligence artificielle forte, ça
va être un espèce d'alien.
si elle a vraiment une conscience
d'elle-même
et je je ne fais pas partie des gens qui
sont persuadés que l'intelligence
artificielle aura conscience d'elle-même
au 21e siècle.
On sera comme face à un alien. On ce
sera un choc d'ailleurs parce que ce
sera la première fois qu'on va partager
la terre avec une autre espèce ayant une
intelligence conceptuelle hein. Depuis
qu'on a zigouillé l'homme de néandertal
il y a 29000 ans, nous homos sapiens
sapiens on est la seule espèce dotée
d'intelligence conceptuelle sur terre.
Le dauphin le dauphin n'en a pas le le
chien
d'intelligence conceptuelle. Il fait pas
de mathématiques, il discute pas de et
puis il discute pas de savoir si Fermi
avait raison dans son hypothèse sur les
raisons pour lesquelles nous ne recevons
pas de signaux électriques
d'extraterrestr Non. Donc euh euh les
animaux ont des formes d'intelligence
non conceptuelles, parfois assez
subtiles.
Il y a aussi des non mammifères qui ont
des des formes d'intelligence fortes. La
corneille a une intelligence euh une
intelligence assez subtile, parfois
supérieure à celle à celle des
chimpanzés, mais ils ont pas
d'intelligence conceptuelle. Donc oui,
ce serait un choc si on a demain une
intelligence artificielle qui a une
conscience d'elle-même. On en est pas là
et je le répète, l'urgence du moment,
c'est l'urgence politique. Comment on
réforme l'éducation pour éviter d'aller
vers un apparta de l'intelligence ?
Une boucherie sociale. Euh, vous avez
des momes ?
Oui.
Quel âge ?
Des ados.
Ils ont eu le droit à la tablette et au
téléphone portable à quel âge ? Euh
ils ont eu droit à l'informatique en
entre 3 et 4 ans et et l'iPhone euh vers
7 ans.
Vous les avez sensibilisé à la vie
privée, au rayonnement wifi et à tous
les dangers inhérents à l'utilisation de
la technologie en
Je suis assez peu castrateur. Donc
l'idée sur laquelle le parent 2017 il
bloque le les appareils électroniques,
il bloque l'accès au sites
pornographique,
il vérifie les logs de connexion des
enfants, il les sermon et il limite le
temps de téléphone portable à 12
secondes par heure. Je trouve c'est une
vision dépassée.
Rétrograde. Ben, c'est un petit peu
comme si on
c'est comme si on contingentait
l'électricité en interdisant nos enfants
d'utiliser l'électricité plus de 5
minutes par heure. Après, une bonne
utilisation de ce qu'on fait des médias
numériques s'impose. Euh, il faut lire
sur euh sa tablette et pas passer son
temps sur Snapchat. Il vaut mieux être
aller sur Twitter que d'aller sur des
discussions stériles sur Facebook. Mais
de contingenter le numérique, c'est pas
dans mon éthique personnelle.
Euh je préfère m'attacher à ce qu'on
fait sur le numérique plutôt que de
contingenter le temps passé sur le
numérique. Certaines études montrent que
l'utilisation de la tablette, du moins
certaines applications sur tablette
activé les mêmes zones du cerveau que la
cocaïne, que le sucre ou
Oui, il y a une il y a clairement une
addiction euh euh notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
au au
qui est qui se ressemble aux addictions
qui ressemblent aux addictions qu'on a
en matière de drogue. Alors, c'est pas
c'est pas exactement la même chose. Il y
a pas une vraie vraie dépendance mais
c'est vrai que quand on reçoit plein de
messages sur Twitter, on frétille, on
est content et que quand on a rien
d'autre à [__] par un dimanche plus
vieux, c'est un petit peu addictif.
Ouais, il va falloir il va falloir
apprendre à être raisonnable. Mais
c'est pas si simple que ça. Sinon, il y
aurait pas d'obésité et on aurait pas
aux États-Unis 40 % de gens qui font
plus de 100 kg, hein. Donc, de ne pas
bouffer du sucre toute la journée, de
passer trop de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux, ça demande une discipline
importante, c'est compliqué, va falloir
l'apprendre aux enfants.
Et s'ils sont trop moyens pour
l'apprendre, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
Est-ce qu'on va se Est-ce qu'on se
dirige vers une forme d'idiocratie ?
Je crois que l'école a un rôle très
important. Je crois que l'école a un
rôle très important pour
donner des normes, pour donner des
normes morales, pour apprendre
l'éthique, l'esprit critique,
pour donner aussi un esprit critique
face au nouveaux médias numériques. Il y
a effectivement des familles qui sont un
peu dépassées, qui ont du mal à former
les enfants, à l'utilisation de ces
outils que qu'elles ne maîtrisent pas
bien. Et là, je crois que l'école a un
vrai vrai rôle à à jouer. C'est pour ça
que je ne crois pas au remplacement de
l'école par des MOX et par
l'enseignement à distance, par des
machines.
L'intelligence collective, l'esprit
critique doivent être appris en groupe
avec les autres enfants. On ne va pas
former des citoyens avec des Mox. Il
faut une vraie école où on se réunisse
et où on est tous ensemble avec les
copains et avec le maître à échanger
sous des formes modernes en utilisant
des outils numériques. Mais il faut être
ensemble. Et je crois beaucoup à une
école rénovée. Je ne crois pas du tout à
une école purement numérique dans le
futur.
Est-ce que le gouvernement vous a
proposé des missions pour
Non, puis je n'aurais pas accepté. Il y
a des gens très bien qui ont des
missions dans sur sur ce domainl. Blanca
a très bien compris les enjeux du
numérique à l'école. Vilan, il est
parfait. Je partage 100 % de ses
diagnostics.
Euh et puis Mounir, il est aussi super.
Donc je vois pas ce que je pourrais
apporter par rapport à des gens aussi
super que Blanca, Mounir et puis Vilani.
Si vous aviez une question à poser à
Cédric Vilani pour notre prochaine
émission, vous vous auriez quoi comme
question à lui poser ? Je lui ai déjà
tout dit. On se parle souvent et donc
j'ai rien à à lui rajouter.
Vous êtes d'accord sur tout tout ?
Oh, moi je suis d'accord avec ce que
tout ce que dit Cédric. Je ne prétends
pas qu'il est d'accord avec tout ce que
je dis mais moi je suis d'accord avec
tout ce qu'il dit. Dans son expression
publique. Il y a pas encore un truc où
j'ai été en désaccord avec Cédric.
Il vous tient un peu au courant de
l'avancée de son rapport.
Pourquoi je suis je ne suis pas un
membre du gouvernement ? le gouvernement
a la primeur de ses réflexions.
On va passer à deux trois petites
questions qui viennent de la communauté,
mais on va juste terminer la la partie
sur les enfants. Euh
eux perçoivent, ils vous en parlent un
petit peu ou pas du tout ? En tant que
ados ou préado, ils viennent vous voir
en vous parlant de leur avenir, de leurs
inquiétudes. Est-ce que la technologie
va les manger ou pas les manger ? Ils
sont pas du tout inquiets,
ils sont curieux,
travailleurs,
euh ils sont particulièrement peu
inquiets sur leur avenir. Ils lisent
énormément
plusieurs livres par semaine,
des essais, des romans, des livres
d'histoire, des livres de philosophie.
Ils n'ont pas l' Ils ne me donnent pas
l'impression d'être paumé dans le monde
qui vient. Ils l'attendent avec
gourmandise.
Je crois qu'ils sont plutôt pas trop mal
armés.
On vous parlez d'armée la jeunesse.
Souvent dans vos interviews, vous parlez
de ces gamins qui apprennent d'une façon
trop centrée, trop polarisée. Vous êtes
plus pour le côté multitâche de d'une
culture générale renforcée. Est-ce que
vous pouvez délayer ça ?
Ben c'est bien le drame de l'école,
c'est que l'école forme aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop de techniciens, de gens
avec un savoir donné, par exemple des
des gens à qui on apprend à être
chauffeur de de de camion, des gens à
qui on apprend d'être comptable, toutes
professions qui vont être balayées par
l'intelligence artificielle. Au lieu de
former des techniciens alors que
l'intelligence artificielle va mieux
faire que les techniciens étroits, il
faut apprendre aux gens à apprendre.
Donc les rendre multidisciplinaires,
leur donner des humanités,
leur apprendre la transversalité, le
travail d'équipe, le travail en groupe,
l'intelligence collective, l'esprit
critique. L'école n'apprend que très peu
tout ça. Il faut cesser d'apprendre des
choses aux enfants. Il faut
principalement leur apprendre à
apprendre. Il faut vraiment obliger les
gamins à lire.
Curieux,
c'est pas c'est pas un slogan pour moi
et c'est ma priorité. Ça a toujours été
ma priorité par rapport à mes enfants.
Un gamin qui ne lit pas trois livres par
semaine était un gamin qui part au
CASPIP face à l'intelligence
artificielle car la lecture est le
principal instrument de formation de
l'esprit critique.
Le langage
et le livre il peut être lu au format
papier ou au format numérique, ça n'a
pas d'importance.
On passe aux questions de notre
communauté.
Alors est-ce que les gens de pouvoir
virgule intelligents n'ont pas une
responsabilité des devoirs envers les
plus faibles de cuit ?
Oui, bien sûr, les élites
intellectuelles ont une responsabilité
vis-à-vis des gens moins doués, sauf que
les élite intellectuels n'en ont rien à
[__] des gens pas doués. Et si les
élites intellectuelles en avaient
quelque chose à faire, des gens moins
doués, et ben on investirait plus dans
l'école et on essayerait de se
rapprocher des standards de qualité des
écoles de Singapour au lieu d'avoir nos
écoles qui sont bien souvent
sous-investis avec des profs sous-payés
et sans moyen. Oui, je le répète et
c'est pas un propos démagogique.
nospes
ou devraient aujourd'hui être au
standard Montessori au lieu d'être ce
qu'elles sont, c'est-à-dire des endroits
qui vont fabriquer des gamins qui vont
être laminés par l'intelligence
artificielle et auxquels demain nos
élites bien pensantes donneront le
revenu universel après les avoir mal
formés et les les avoir envoyé au CASPIP
face à l'intelligence artificielle. Oui,
il y a une responsabilité écrasante des
élites intellectuelles dans la crise
sociale et politique qui arrive. Il faut
investir massivement sur la recherche et
sur l'éducation, sauf que ces
segments-là n'intéressent pas nos élite
politique.
Je vais me faire un peu l'avocat du
diable. Euh ça les intéresse pas parce
que ils font un peu comme les blackcat,
c'est ils ont perdu confiance dans leur
congénère à pouvoir se sortir un peu de
cette boue. Non,
il pense il pensent que ils sont que le
la plebe est trop conne pour se sortir.
Non, c'est pas du tout ça.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Non non,
c'est que les élites les élites
politiques ne sont pas prêts à payer le
prix qu'il faut pour rénover
l'éducation. Le
le prix,
il faut considérablement augmenter le
niveau du recrutement qui a baissé ces
dernières années. Il faut qu'un jeune
polytechnicien, qu'un jeune HC, qu'un
jeune diplômé de subd ou de centrale
puisse être instituteur dans la France
de 2020. Donc il doit être payé au prix
d'un jeune polytechnicien. Sinon, le
niveau ne sera pas suffisant pour aider
les gamins à monter dans l'ascenseur
social. à l'air de l'intelligence
artificielle, nous devons mettre les
meilleurs cerveaux français comme prof,
comme prof de collège, comme comme
instituteur qu'on appelle maintenant euh
d'un nom différent mais qu'on appelait
instituteur quand moi j'étais j'étais
gamin. Si nous ne faisons pas ça, et
bien nous allons effectivement créer un
appartide avec les enfants de la haute
bourgeoisie qui vont continuer à mettre
leurs gamins dans des écoles montessori
à prix d'Or et puis les gamins du peuple
qui vont être pas bien formés dans des
mauvaise qualité. Et c'est ça qui
conduit à un cauchemar politique. Les
politiques doivent aujourd'hui être
courageux.
Il faut être capable d'avoir des
polytechniciens
preuve de collège. Il faut être capable
d'avoir de jeunes polytechniciens
instituteurs. Ça suppose d'augmenter
considérablement la rémunération
des enseignants pour avoir le meilleur.
Car les meilleurs cerveaux biologiques
de France doivent être enseignants.
Et pour les attirer dans l'éducation, il
faut leur montrer qu'on les aime, qu'on
considère que leur mission est cruciale
et il faut les payer le juste prix. ce
que l'on fait à Singapour. C'est pour ça
que Singapour est aujourd'hui numéro 1
mondial dans PISA. C'est pour ça qu'à
Singapour, on est [grognement] ils sont
numéro 1 en terme de caution
intellectuelle avec 10 points de caution
intellectuel de plus que les jeunes
français. Et c'est pour ça qu'à
Singapour, le niveau de vie par habitant
est quasiment le double de ce qu'il est
en France alors que Singapour était un
pays sous-développé il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça.
Alors une autre question de l'internet
qui est un peu redondante. Une personne
dite intelligente ne devrait-elle pas se
donner pour devoir de réduire les les
inégalités ?
Bien sûr, le seul but de l'économie,
c'est de réduire les inégalités au 21e
siècle. Et donc le but de l'économie, le
but de la politique, c'est de réduire
les inégalités. Or dans le monde qui
vient, je le répète, les inégalités
intellectuelles vont être la source de
toutes les inégalités. Les gens
intelligents auront de plus en plus tous
les pouvoirs parce que l'intelligence
artificielle va faire mieux que la
plupart d'entre nous les tâches simples.
Donc il ne va rester que des tâches
transversales et très compliquées à
faire. et ce sont les gens dotés de la
plus forte intelligence conceptuelle qui
vont avoir ces emploislà et qui donc
auront tous les pouvoirs dans la société
qui vient. C'est pour ça que l'éducation
est une véritable urgence et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut notamment mettre le paquet
sur les classes sociales défavorisées,
sur les classes économiques
défavorisées, sur les zones
géographiques défavorisées. Et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut mettre des écoles au
standard Montessori en commençant par le
93 parce qu'il est totalement injuste
que seuls les enfants de la haute
bourgeoisie aient aujourd'hui une
éducation au standard Montessori ou
équivalent ce qui va accentuer les
inégalités. Ça tombe bien, nous sommes
dans le 93 à Saint-Denis.
Ça ne m'avait pas échappé.
Je ne vais pas reformuler la question
qui vient d'internet. Je vous la pose
comme ça brute et tout le monde sentira
les interconnexions de cette cette
question.
Que pensent-t-il de la capacité de
violence des bas cuits ?
Est-ce que les gens cons sont violents ?
Absolument pas.
Mais si nous ne diminuons pas les
inégalités intellectuelles,
la marginalisation des gens les moins
doués que l'on aura pas formé et que
l'on aura pas fait évoluer
se vengeront
en refusant de moderniser l'école va
être terrible et va conduire à une
situation révolutionnaire. Ne nous y
trompons pas. Dans une société de
l'intelligence artificielle, s'il y a
des écarts de capacité intellectuelle
importante, nous aurons la révolution.
Mais pas une révolution comme 1968, une
révolution comme 1793.
La société va imploser si nous ne
modernisons pas de toute urgence le
système éducatif mais va imploser car
effectivement face à une intelligence
artificielle ubicuitaire
et quasi gratuite, il n'y aura pas
beaucoup de place pour des gens que nous
n'aurons pas bien formés, qui n'auront
pas d'esprit critique, qui n'auront pas
lu et qui en réalité vont être des
paumés du numérique, vont être des
naufragés du numérique, vont être des
naufragés de la société de la
connaissance
là là vous êtes déprimé ou vous êtes
réaliste ?
Je suis totalement réaliste.
Parfait. Autre autre question de
l'internet. Alors concrètement c'est
quoi l'intelligence artificielle dans le
futur ? IROT point d'interrogation objet
connecté point d'interrogation
algorithme point d'interrogation. Il
faut essayer de d'interconnecter tout ça
les gars parce que là
personne aujourd'hui n'est capable de
dire ce que va donner l'intelligence
artificielle et si elle va acquérir une
conscience artificielle c'estàd de
devenir une intelligence artificielle
forte. C'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure personne. Donc on peut
échafauder des scénarios. C'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire dans mon bouquin la
guerre des intelligences. Euh il va
falloir réfléchir à ces questions en
matière d'intelligence artificielle. On
n'a pas assez réfléchi aux normes hein.
Quelle norme éthique on donne à
l'intelligence artificielle ? On en
parlait tout à l'heure. Comment
va-t-elle évoluer ? Comment peut-on
travailler avec l'intelligence
artificielle ? Faut-il la surveiller ?
Faut-il faire attention à ce qu'elle ne
devienne pas hostile ? Toutes ces
questionsl vont se poser dans les
décennies qui viennent. Euh il y a une
réflexion
assez évoluée dans la Silicone Vallée
sur la question de la sécurité.
notamment Elon Mosk a a monté une
fondation pour évaluer la dangerosité
des intelligences artificielles. En
Europe, on y travaille pas suffisamment.
il va falloir y aller et ça ça c'est une
urgence en terme de recherche. Il
faudrait qu'il y ait des bons chercheurs
qui réfléchissent sur ces questions là.
Quand on voit dans la Silicon Valallé
certains qui émettent l'hypothèse de
créer une religion par l'intelligence
artificiel, de créer son cybergod,
un avis dessus, est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est encore
l'intelligence artificielle est une
bombe pour les religions ?
D'abord parce que en créant Homodéus
l'intelligence artificielle pose un
problème aux religions.
L'homme va faire ce que seul Dieu
pouvait faire.
C'est un très bon livre.
Tuer la mort,
augmenter notre cerveau, coloniser le
cosmos,
nous augmenter. L'homme va être pourvu
de pouvoir quasi divin avec
l'intelligence artificielle et ça va
bien évidemment choquer les religions,
notamment la mort de la mort. qui n'est
pas pour demain matin, mais
dans le futur, nous ne serons plus
mortels. Et les religions
sont quand même basé sur l'idée que la
mort est inéluctable. Donc ça c'est un
premier problème. Le deuxième problème,
c'est que de nouvelles religions basées
sur l'intelligence artificielle vont
arriver. On voit dans la Silicone Vallée
des gens comme Lewandowski créer une
religion centrée sur l'IA, c'est-à-dire
l'intelligence artificielle devenant
un nouveau dieu. Donc on va avoir
des nouvelles religions.
Le développement du transhumanisme qui
est en réalité une religion particulière
qui pense que Dieu n'existe pas encore
mais va exister demain. C'est nous
augmenter grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle. Tout ça va [__] un grand
bordel pour les religions. La religion
catholique va avoir un problème
particulier, c'est qu'en réalité les
transhumanistes
et l'Église catholique pensent pareil
sur l'âme. L'Église catholique pense que
l'âme n'est pas dans notre cerveau,
qu'elle est donnée par Dieu, qu'elle
n'est pas produite par les neurones.
C'est l'hypothèse dualiste que
Saint-Augustin au 5e siècle a a a
posé.
Mais les transhumanistes pensent pareil
puisqu'ils imaginent que notre
conscience peut-être mise sur des
microprocesseurs indépendamment de nos
neurones. Donc on voit qu'entre les
transhumanistes et en fait les
chrétiens, il y a une porosité
intellectuelle et qu'il va y avoir une
contamination de l'Église catholique par
les transhumanistes. Je pense que
l'église catholique est la plus menacée
des religions à l'air du transhumanisme
et de l'intelligence artificielle, même
si elle ne s'en rend pas encore compte.
parce que la réflexion de l'Église
catholique sur ces sujets-là est très
embryonnaire à part quelques
intellectuels comme Thomas Geoffrey ou
ou le père Rouget.
Bon, il nous reste il nous reste
quelques minutes encore avec vous. Euh
moderniser alors voilà moderniser le
système éducatif virgule c'est faire des
citoyens pointus.
Est-ce que les politiciens le veulent
vraiment ? des gens qui pensent
les politiciens
ne sont pas méchants.
Ils sont pas m
Les politiciens ils ne complotent pas.
Les politiciens ne veulent pas du tout
d'une masse à servi. Simplement ils sont
lâches et ils sont pas courageux. Et
donc ils ne sont pas prêts, comme je
disais tout à l'heure à payer le prix
pour moderniser le système éducatif
parce que ça va être très compliqué. de
faire venir comme instituteur des
polytechniciens.
Ça a un coup mais surtout ça va [__]
un tel bordel dans l'éducation que aucun
ministre n'est prêt à assumer ça. Parce
que quand les instituteurs actuels vont
voir arriver un jeune à chaussée,
ils vont se sentir tout petit et ils
vont faire une crise
existentielle majeure et ça va être
compliqué à gérer.
Les instituteurs n'ont pas imaginé que
dans la France de 2030, les gens les
plus intelligents seront instituteurs ou
seront dans les crèches et qu'on va
mettre des bacs + 10 diplômés en
neurosciences dans les crèches. Et
aujourd'hui où dans les crèches, il y a
parfois
des gens qui n'ont même pas le bac, ça
va être un
ça va être un vrai choc. Oui, mais ça va
pas suffire. Face à l'intelligence
artificielle d'avoir des gentils gamins
avec des gentils éducateurs de crèche
bac- ça va pas le faire. C'est
sympathique mais c'est juste conduire
les gamins au caspip. Soit on est
capable de bombarder la Californie et la
Chine pour leur interdire de développer
l'intelligence artificielle, soit on
n'est pas capable. Il se trouve qu'on
n'est pas capable. Le budget militaire
européen, il est famélique. Puisqu'on
n'est pas capable d'empêcher les
nouvelles puissances économiques et
technologiques de développer
l'intelligence artificielle, il va
falloir qu'on vive dans un monde où il y
a de l'intelligence artificielle et donc
former nos enfants pour qu'ils soient
compétitifs dans ce monde que nous ne
pouvons pas empêcher. Et donc, nous
n'avons pas le choix
d'avoir des éducateurs sympathiques et
empathiques ne va pas suffire. Il va
falloir
quand les gamins sont à la crèche
le moment magique où un million de
synapses neuronales secré chaque
seconde, il va falloir profiter de ce
moment-là en mettant des gens
extrêmement intelligents et très forts
en neuroscience pour permettre au gamin
de faire les bons les plus élevés
possible pour tout faire pour qu'on
réduise les inégalités intellectuelles.
Et s'il y a un moment où on peut réduire
les inégalités intellectuelles, c'est
bien à ce moment-là la toute petite
enfance quand le cerveau se câble, c'est
bien à ce moment-là qu'il faut agir. Il
faut mettre les gens les plus
intelligents de France dans les
maternels et dans le primaire. On a
compris,
c'est un vrai sujet
et ça va être terriblement compliqué à
expliquer à l'éducation nationale
qui ne se rend pas compte que c'est à ce
prix-là que nous pourrons réduire les
inégalités intellectuelles et donc les
inégalités sociales.
Question. Ouais, bon courage les gars.
Avant-dernière question. HC au
polytechnique, c'est pour être adapté
dans le monde tel qu'il va continuer.
Mais est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut pas
changer le système ?
Vous savez, contrairement à ce qu'on
pense les HC, les polytechniciens, c'est
pas des techniciens, ils ont une grande
culture générale.
Les polytechniciens lisent plus de
livres et ont plus de culture littéraire
que les comptables.
Bon euh, on va passer, je vous prépare
la dernière question qu'on pose à tous
nos invités qui est laisser un conseil
pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer, un truc qui sera
impérissable, immortel sur internet.
Donc, préparez-vous à cette question. Je
vais vous poser d'autres questions un
peu plus funky. Vous avez déjà pris de
la drogue ?
Jamais.
Vous avez déjà été au commissariat
euh pour avoir malgaré ma voiture ?
Pour avoir
malgaré ma voiture
et oui mais que pour ça.
Ouais.
Euh
et je et je déconseille à vos auditeurs
de prendre des drogues,
de prendre de la drogue. Je rappelle
juste que la consommation chronique du
hashich diminue le caution intellectuel
de 8 points. 8 points, c'est ce qui
sépare le quotient intellectuel moyen
d'une infirmière et le caution
intellectuel moyen d'un docteur. C'est
ce qui sépare le quotiion intellectuel
moyen d'un ingénieur et d'un technicien
supérieur. Donc quand on est gamin,
prendre régulièrement du hashich, ça
veut dire être demain très peu
compétitif face à l'intelligence
artificielle. Le haschich est un
destructeur de caution intellectuelle.
Mon point de vue, il est pas moral, il
est totalement pragmatique.
Ouais. Vous vous basez sur quelles
études ?
La corte néoz-élandaise qui est
accessible à tout le monde et qui est
terrifiante sur ce sujet-là, qui pendant
des décennies a suivi les consommateurs
réguliers de Hachich.
C'est à pleurer de tristesse.
Comment vous expliquez que les hackurs
consomment énormément de drogue ?
Ils ont tort.
C'est une explication comme une autre.
Je connais des tas de gens qui fument
trois paquets de cigarettes par jour,
ils ont tort. Vous
avez jamais fumé un joint ?
J'ai jamais fumé un joint parce que je
ne voulaz pas
devenir accro au joints. Je n'ai aucun
regret puisque je n'ai jamais essayé. Ça
ne m'a jamais manqué. Si j'avais
consommé des joints, ça me manquerait.
Bon, on va on va vous réinviter une
prochaine fois une prochaine fois pour
étudier les mécanismes d'addictologie.
Notre dernière question pour les jeunes
générations. Un petit conseil à laisser
comme ça. Un truc hésitez pas à ce que
ce soit piquant.
Faut pas hésiter à dire les choses.
Au lieu de passer votre vie sur
Snapchat, lisez trois bouquins par
semaine.
Ça vous l'avez dit sur tous les plateaux
télé. un autre.
C'est très paternaliste hein comme
demande. Moi je suis pas très
paternaliste. Je pense que mon avis est
pas
est pas très pertinent pour les jeunes
générations. Donc j'ai pas grand chose à
dire
pour l'euthanasie ou pas ?
Je suis pour mon droit personnel
à disposer de votre vie.
À disposer de ma vie et de ma mort.
Je suis totalement hostile à une
athanasie d'état, à une euthanasie
imposée, totalement opposée. Et je suis
assez attaché à mon
à mon droit à mourir, notamment
si on ne fait pas de progrès dans le
traitement de l'Alzheimer et il y a
toujours aucun médicament efficace dans
l'Alzheimer.
Je préfère pouvoir me flinguer plutôt
que que d'être
10 ans dans un Alzheimerium
avec mes enfants qui s'emmerderont à
venir me voir une fois tous les 3 mois
et que je ne reconnaîtrai pas.
Faud appeler, faudra nous appeler, on
vous balancera de la falaise, on vous
mettra un petit dans la bouche histoire
que ça se passe bien, qu'il y ait pas de
stress. Vous voulez vous remercier
d'être venu jusqu'ici. Euh vous avez
toujours été très sympa avec nous malgré
nos nombreux coup defil, nos nombreux
SMS même le dimanche et et vous êtes un
homme très pris dans le souvent dans les
trains. On a pu le constater. Vous êtes
toujours resté super cool avec nous et
c'était important de le dire parce que
quand on vous a annoncé
il y en a certains qui vous ont plombé
et voilà et on aime bien dire ce qu'on
voit, ce qu'on teste, ce qu'on goûte, ce
qu'on essaye.
[raclement de gorge]
J'espère que vos auditeurs liront la
guerre des intelligences.
Ah bah nous nous on a été obligé de
l'acheter mais montrez-le, je vous le
passe. [rires]
Il va falloir nous nouser.
Franchement franchement franchement il
est très bien.
Ouais ouais ouais.
Non franchement c'est mon meilleur
bouquin et franchement il se vend il se
vend comme des petits pains et
franchement il est très bien.
Ah tiens, en parlant de ça, qui est-ce
qui s'occupe de la communication sur
Facebook a sponsorisé toutes vos
publications ? Et qui est-ce qui
s'occupe ?
Ah je sais pas, c'est pas moi.
C'est pas vous ?
Non. Bon, en tous les cas,
mais j'ai des j'ai des j'ai des femmes
fans qui sont très attachés à la
promotion de mes idées. C'est c'est
rigolo et sympathique. Bon, en tous les
cas, merci et puis excellente journée et
on remercie la communauté d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce direct et à la
prochaine. No.
[musique]